well local firefighters called this the
weekend of health
tackling multiple fish fires on multiple
fronts
this was a case of just hanging on
saving what they could after six weeks
of this fight teams are exhausted but
they are not giving up people volunteer
they they don't just want to help their
own community they're somewhat Patrick
patriotical about the country and the
state and the service and they they like
to go on assist to wherever they can
whoever not just being their own
backyard today the Australian Prime
Minister pledged more support for
full-time firefighters they issued a
directive to all Commonwealth
departments and agencies that will see
the full paid leave for emergency
services be lifted to a minimum standard
of four weeks four weeks and with
additional leave able to be provided by
those agencies on an adze needs basis
but in New South Wales the vast majority
of fire crews are volunteers so it's up
to communities to look after their own
every day for the past six weeks
Doreen Peters were sourced prepared and
delivered more than two hundred lunches
for fire crews it's a job she's taken on
during the fire season for more than 54
years thank you so much just wonderful
they've been out for weeks and weeks and
weeks fighting these fires and they need
the nourishment because when they go
home they just they want to share and go
to bed because they're too tired so at
least we're trying to give them a decent
meal at lunchtime
in this battle not every hero holds a
hose Katrin over top sees Sky News in
the Blue Mountains